- Good morning Believe Nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe that you
have something special that
when you unleash it, it will
be able to change the world.
So, to help you on your journey,
today's message is live
your life to the fullest.
Over to you, Oprah Winfrey.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- What drives you to keep working so hard?
You and I are in the 60s category.
And so when you're in your 60s,
you know you've lived more
than you're going to live,
realistically.
- Yeah.
- So, when you realize you've lived
more than you're going
to live you can say,
why not relax a little bit?
Why not just ease up?
Why have you decided to even work harder
than you did before?
- Because I think, David, that everybody
you know, the thing that works for me
all these years whether it was
the magazine, which I still have,
or whether it was the show,
I understood that there's
a common denominator
in the human experience.
And I want the same thing you want,
which is the same thing
you want and you want.
What we all want is to be able to live out
the truest, highest expression
of ourselves as a human being.
That doesn't end until
you take your last breath.
What is the truest, highest vision
that you hold for yourself?
No matter where you are in your life,
there's always the next level.
There's always a next
level to the last breath.
So, I feel that I always knew that
I would be done with the show when
I felt like, oh, I've said as much
as I could say here on this platform.
And then how will I be used?
If there were a theme song to my life,
Amazing Grace would be one of them
and Keep On Using Me to Use Me Up
would be another one.
(audience laughs)
You know that Bill Withers song?
♫ Da, da, da, daa
So, I feel that until you have used
your value as a human
being, you're not done.
- I don't think most people
live their life to the fullest.
I don't think people are even close.
I don't think most people are even
anywhere close to living
their life to the fullest.
I think most people are waiting
for the weekends to come,
can't wait for that vacation to come.
If you are counting down
the days to your vacation,
then, in my view, I
think there's something
wrong with your life.
Now, there's nothing wrong with vacations,
there's nothing wrong with weekends.
I love spending time with my family,
I love my weekends.
I love vacations when
I go off to vacations.
But the thing is, you want to
be running towards something.
Like, a vacation or a weekend
or activities that you have
should be something you run towards.
But for most people a
vacation or a weekend
is a running away from their current life.
Your job sucks, your life sucks,
and so you want to just go away,
sit on the beach for two weeks
and not have to worry about anything.
That's not great.
Like, if you get to only get off
for one or two weeks a year
and then you're looking
forward to the weekends
and you're spending most of your life
doing work that you hate,
that's not anywhere close to
living your life to the fullest.
Most people don't even know what
living their life to
the fullest looks like.
And so that's to you, if
you like dread the work
that you're doing, you're
in the wrong thing.
You got to go off and do something else.
That's why having
passion for your business
is the most important
ingredient to success,
'cause if you're only
chasing an opportunity,
you'll only have some big goal,
you're not going to do
the work to get there.
You'll say you'll do anything,
whatever it takes, right,
I'll do whatever it takes
to get there but you won't.
Because you're only motivated by the goal
where you have to enjoy the daily process.
You have to actually enjoy the work.
And again, not everyday is amazing.
Not every day is insanely successful.
I don't wake up everyday
and have the best day ever.
There's a lot of crap
you have to deal with
to be an entrepreneur.
But net, like, I enjoy the work I'm doing.
I enjoy making YouTube
videos for you guys.
I enjoy responding to the comments.
I enjoy running Toronto Dance Salsa.
I enjoy helping build Lily
up to be an entrepreneur.
I enjoy net, the work that I do
and you need to do the
same thing in your business
if you want to come anywhere close
to living your life to your fullest.
I agree with the Oprah in
that there is no end point.
Like it's until your last breath.
You're doing it because you love to do it.
If you love doing the thing,
why do you want to stop?
If you're looking for a finish line
and you can't wait to retire,
you're in the wrong thing.
If you're counting the
days 'til your retirement
or the vacation or the weekend,
you are doing the wrong thing
and you need to stop ASAP
to move yourself and then
you can look forward too.
There is no final date.
It's ongoing.
It's forever.
It's lifetime.
It's to your last breath.
That has to be the thing.
And if you don't know what
that this, that's okay.
Explore.
Search.
Find it.
Don't just sit on your
hands doing the same thing
over and over and over and over again
because the path of finding
what that things is for you
that you can live your fullest life
and enjoy the work that you're doing,
does not come from sitting on the couch
and staying in the life that you hate.
That's not how you find it.
You got to get out there and explore.
I also applaud Oprah for
leaving the Oprah Winfrey Show
at the height of her career.
She had the number one talk show.
She had tons of influence.
Millions of people following her.
And she decides to go out.
Like she wasn't an athlete that...
you're going to fade over time, right?
It's not like her skills are diminishing
and she's going to fall
off the cliff, right?
You know, you're a 50 year
old basketball player.
You can have a hard time keepin' up.
She was at the height of her game
and she decided to quit and move on
because she felt like that part
of her life was done, right?
She had said what she wanted
to say but she wasn't done,
she wasn't retiring, she was moving on
just to the next chapter.
And so I have a lot of respect for her
of quitting the thing at
the height of her career
to then move on and try
something brand new.
And I did the same thing with my business
where I had my website
and that was the thing.
I was all in on my website.
And now I barely spend
any of time on my website.
It's still there.
It's still a business.
I still help my team, we're growing it.
But more of my effort is focused on
the YouTube channel for you guys.
For TDS.
Lily, I'm mentoring in building her up.
The other projects that I'm working on.
And if I ever get sick
of the YouTube channel,
if I ever have to think,
"Oh god, I make YouTube vidoes, it sucks!
"I hate it!"
If that's ever my mindset
going into filming day,
I have to quit.
Like I will move on.
I might sell the channel
or I just might stop it.
If you get to that point, right?
You got to be able to
move on to something else.
Now, thankfully, for me and for you guys,
I love this.
Like I love--
I want to get better.
I want to drive forward.
I want to hit the next goal.
I want to make these videos even better,
even more impactful for you guys.
But this may not continue in five years,
in ten years, in 30 years.
I'm still going to be
doing things that help
inspire and building an entrepreneurs.
It may not be through YouTube.
YouTube may not even be around.
And that's okay.
Like the minute you
start losing your passion
for whatever it is that you're doing,
you need to move on.
You might be able to sell the
thing that you made, right?
And give it to somebody else.
Or it may not be big enough to sell.
That's okay.
Drop it and move on to something else.
As soon as you lose that passion
for whatever it that you're doing,
you need to move on and go
find something else ASAP
because the window is closing.
You only have so much time on this planet.
You want to do something that's meaningful
and stop counting down
the days to next weekend,
to next vacation, to your retirement day.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
what is the thing that
makes you come alive most?
What do you love most about
the business that you started
or the business you want to start?
Or something in your personal life?
Like what is the thing that you wish
you could do all day long?
It makes you feel the most alive.
What is that thing for you?
Leave it down the comments below.
Really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to LaTrenda George.
LaTrenda, thank you so much
for picking a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
I really really appreciate the support.
And I hope you enjoy the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love
and I'll see you guys
again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- Someone on another
interview was just asking me.
"Hey, you know, back in the early days,
"you guys released an
album almost every year.
"You got like five albums
in six years or somethin'
"and what happened?
"It was eight years since
the last one honestly, dude."
There's a lot more to life to do.
There's a lot, you know.
Vacations with families,
watching my kids grow up.
Touring a lot longer than it used to be.
Shit, back in those days
we had this many songs
and this is how many gigs we can do
and then we're back in the studio, so.
A lot is happening in life and
everyone in the band is on the same page
which is really a great thing.
We've all got kids.
And we've all got other lives.
But we can't live without Metallica, man.
It's just somethin'
that joins us, you know.
We're these friggin'
four married guys that
know more about each other
than anyone knows about us,
maybe our wives.
- If you come to the idea
of mortality once in a way,
it will make you depressed.
It will make you fearful.
If you live with it every moment,
it will make you absolutely
exuberant and alive.
Because it is just this one thing.
That this is not forever.
This is just for a brief period of time.
And the more joyful you
are, briefer it becomes.
If you're ecstatic, it will
just vanish in no time.
(laughs)
Yes?
So if you want to stretch it,
you need to make yourself truly miserable.
(audience laughs)
Otherwise, it'll be just gone in no time.
If you come to terms with
this, if you live this way,
that every moment, you
appreciate one thing
and only one thing.
Because the most important
thing in your life is
you're alive right now.
To be alive.
Fully alive.
100% alive is the most important thing
because only if something is 100% alive,
can you make it ill something beautiful.